So now that we've gone through
this exercise let's put these
pieces together.
We showed three separate results
that being able to find the best, or
nearly the best,
let's you make few mistakes.
Being able to make few mistakes let's
you do well on average per step.
Being able to do well
on average per step
gives you the ability to
actually find a nearly best arm.
So, all these things
are actually equivalent.
If you give me an algorithm for
doing any one of these, I can derive
something for doing the other two.
Just kind of do it in a circle here.
So, in a sense what
this is telling us is,
that we kind of don't have to
pick among these three different
optimality criteria because they're
really all the same as each other.
And you could sort of say, well and
it must be that these are the right
ones to think about because
even if we don't think about this
doing well on average per step,
we would have to solve it anyway if we
cared about any of these other things.
So,
>> Hm.
>> I don't know.
What I get out of this is the idea that
whichever of these is most convenient
for you to work with,
you should just work with it because
the other ones are going to fall out.
And there's other optimality criteria
that you could worry about, but
I don't know, it seems like a lot
of them come back down to these.
>> Yeah, I like that a lot.
You're really saying that they're
kind of in an equivalence class
of difficulty.
>> Yes.
Now interestingly,
the thing that we haven't done yet, and
that we need to do, is show that we
can solve any of these problems.
I thought we just did.
We put a lot of words on some
screens and there were some taus.
>> [LAUGH] No, no, no.
No, what we showed was that if you could
solve one, you could solve the other.
If you could solve that one,
you could solve.
But, we never said that any of
these are actually solvable.
So, we need one more result to
kind of make this all doable.
>> Okay, that's fair, but
I was satisfied with proof by tau,
but if you want to actually go and
ground it out.
>> Yeah, but the taus were all
defined in terms of other taus.
It never bottomed out.
Right, what'd we'd really
like is something that says,
here is an algorithm that will in
a polynomial number of trials find you
a nearly optimal arm.
>> I don't know, Michael, it seems to
me this is pretty straight forward.
It's taus all the way down.
>> It can't be taus all the way down.
>> Why not?
It's turtles,
they start with the same sound.
>> That's true.
I guess they're Greek turtles.
>> Yes,
it's Greek turtles all the way down,
which is what we've always suspected.